you already know man bootleg cat podcast
my guy j stone about to do what he does
man you already know what time it is
definition of sacrifice june 15th june
15th man
let's get it yeah
[Music]
uh
here boy what up
naz what up
bullet kev what up yes sir let's get it
let's go
uh
remy in my cup cushion the blunt v12 on
the side double him in the front we need
to argue who the best at it you know
that the west bend had it [ __ ] just
added we ain't need to argue about
numbers [ __ ] them checks matter check
my success status talk about stats [ __ ]
i'm running laps not to mention these
rap [ __ ] i'm overlapping they be lying
in eight raps they be over capping i
played the block like they was my own
street snazz tunnel by the block i'm
trying to really on streets
lost way too many homies nowadays just
seem to ops can be the homies uh
that's why i keep it on me i dare wanted
you rap [ __ ] to speak up on me i got
two rollies on call me two rolly stoney
reach your swiss
[Music]
you [ __ ] be on clubhouse snitching you
know the fans just listening that's a
mouse trap rats are sniffing in [ __ ]
business they don't need a witness
that's why i keep my distance y'all
gonna get a [ __ ] sentence can't let you
trick me on my spot you know the devil
plotting you know them birds watching i
leveled up a notch i put up on johnny
dang to level up my watch he made me a
grill got murdered on the spot i'm at
the dock putting bad [ __ ] on the
yacht triple deck they say is lonely at
the top uh
maybach bins made back rims no deal
cause it's better on the back end they
keep asking why i'm living like that
they say the good die young so i'm
living life fast
now i'm selling out shows [ __ ] pay up
look how far around and came up straight
up look this [ __ ] written in stone i'm
ducking [ __ ] that be digging for gold
that ain't up lifting my soul record
labels they keep hitting my phone but i
ain't got too many answers i just been
in my zone i got bigger options i got
bigger profits i have so much clothes i
need a bigger closet i had so much dough
i needed bigger pockets
[Music]
[ __ ] come on
[Music]
come on man june 15th [ __ ] go
get the album yeah
let's get it
let's get it [ __ ] hey i know you just
watched a brand new freestyle presented
to you by our good folks at lrg don't
forget if you go to lrg right now the
website will be right there broom l dash
r dash g dot com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get thirty percent off your order that's
l dash r dash g dot com you'll see it
right down there
save 30 off your order by putting in
that promo code bootleg and shout out to
lrg we got another freestyle coming next
week